alright let's get started um today we're
gonna continue our discussion of factor
markets if you call last Monday we
started talking about the labor market
and we talked about how workers make the
decision between work and leisure and we
talked about the implications for
setting the wage rate in the labor
market what I want to do today is return
to that labor market equilibrium and
talk about the important case of the
minimum wage so today I want to talk
about the labor market equilibrium and
how it's affected by the minimum wage
because it's an interesting case which
allows us to introduce some
complications to how we think about the
labor market so let's go back and think
about the labor market so let's go to
figure 16 1 ok the labor market like any
other market has a price at a quantity
the quantity is the amount of Labor
supplied that's on the x axis the price
is the wage that's on the y axis the
supply curve that's upward sloping
typically we'll assume an upward sloping
supply curve but as we discussed last
time that doesn't have to be true ok if
income effects dominate substitution
effects which a very amount well may you
could actually have a backward bending
or downward sloping supply curve ok so
we talked about that last time having
taught that interesting case typically
we'll assume supply is upward sloping or
at least not not backwards bending not
downward sloping ok but remember that's
an assumption
so Stoppard sloping supply curve is not
necessarily as obvious as a downward
sloping demand curve is downward sloping
demand will almost always exist unless
there's a weird giving good
whereas upward sloping supply is a
little more questionable so we have the
equilibrium and we have this equilibrium
at l1 workers at a wage w1 so now we
know where this comes from
so basically going all the way back to
producer theory we just gave you a W now
we're telling where the W comes from
we're telling you where the wage comes
from that you then plug into the firm's
optimization for them to produce produce
goods now let's imagine that we add a
minimum wage so let's go to figure 16 2
so this is a regulation which says that
you're not allowed to pay workers but
some minimum level and let's say we set
that minimum wage at the level w2 above
the market wage W one quick question
what would happen if we pass the law in
sedima minimum wage that was below w1 so
it'd be a regulation which insisting you
couldn't pay workers below w2 but W is
below w1 what would that do to the labor
market nothing and here's the key point
labor markets in economics will always
endeavor to avoid government regulations
as if they can so if a government
regulation is not binding it won't
matter markets will just avoid it okay
so the interesting case is only where
the minimum wage is binding as in the
figure figure 16 - okay
so what happens well if you set a mum
wage minimum wage at w2 workers at that
high wage would love to work a lot
that's high wage they're high in the
supply curve they would like to work l
sub s hours okay they would like to fly
L sub s amount of labour supply to the
market firms however if forced to pay a
high wage w2 are gonna say wait I'm only
want to pay that high wage if the
marginal if the marginal revenue product
of labor is sufficiently high remember
we talked about the marginal revenue
product last time it's the marginal
product of labor times the price so if
you're gonna raise the wage you have to
pay workers I'm unlucky FEX the market
price I'm gonna need to have a higher
marginal product of labor right the
demand equation was I set the wage equal
to the marginal product of labor times
the price well if the price hasn't
changed with the minimum wage going in
I'm gonna need a high if the wage is
forced up by the minimum wage I'm gonna
need a higher marginal product of labor
how do I get a higher marginal product
of labor by hiring less workers because
the marginal product of labor is
diminishing so if you're gonna force me
to pay a higher wage you're gonna force
me to only hire workers until the point
where the marginal product of labor
justifies the higher wage which means
I'm gonna hire fewer workers so firms
demand only L sub D well workers can't
get jobs firms don't want to give so the
equilibrium is L sub D jobs at a wage W
sub - ok what is this
due to welfare we can see before before
the minimum wage was in place the market
featured a a consumer surplus now here
consumers are firms right but there was
a consumer surplus of a plus B plus C
that is firms were willing to pay what
was on the demand curve they only had to
pay w1 so their surplus was a plus B
plus C fur workers were willing to work
at a wage that's given by the supply
curve S sub 1 they were paid at W sub 1
so they got a surplus of D plus C so
here the firm's get the consumer surplus
the workers get the producer surplus
because the workers are now the
producers now let's say you roll in the
set of minimum wage well two things have
happened
one thing is you've then transferred
some resources to workers that's the
area B you've taken the area B that
firms used to get and now workers get it
that's the idea you want to make workers
better off so transferred to workers the
area B on the other hand you've created
a deadweight loss of the area c plus e
tred deadweight loss of the air c plus C
because now there are fewer jobs there
are workers who would happily work at
the wage at a higher wage who are not
being allowed to work by by the limited
demand that comes to the minimum wage
okay so the bottom line is you end up
with fewer workers a higher wage and
ambiguous welfare implications clearly
social welfare goes down whether worker
welfare goes up or not depends a bit on
the size of area B versus the size of
area E okay it's not clear if worker
surplus goes up or not depends on the
size of B versus e in this diagram
workers are a net better off but doesn't
have to be true what's clear is that
social welfares gone down because the
number because remember as I talked
about the cheat the shortcut I talked
about we talked about oligopoly is
roughly speaking welfare is proportional
to the quantity in the market okay
essentially the further you deviate from
the perfectly competitive quantity the
bigger the deadweight loss so that's
what happens you put in the minimum wage
questions about that okay
well that seems pretty straightforward
and that's what I learned growing up as
a kid an economics class um but then
some empirical economists some very
famous empirical economists started
doing a series of articles that actually
studied gee what happens with minimum
wage does change they did things like
for example comparing what happened when
New Jersey raised its minimum wage but
the state of Pennsylvania next door did
not and looked at fast-food workers in
New Jersey where the man wage went up
career to fast-food workers in
Pennsylvania with a non wage didn't go
up and what they found was there was no
difference in employment that jobs
didn't fall in New Jersey even though
the minimum wage went up okay and a
series of follow-on studies continued to
find that actually higher minimum wages
didn't seem to cause jobs to fall which
is sort of directly in contradiction
with its graph so what's going on that
led to sort of big questioning a
revision it's kind of what's going on in
these markets that leads to that and
there's really three possibilities for
what's going on possibility one is that
the minimum wage wasn't binding maybe
New Jersey said minimum wage below the
market wage but actually empirically
that's not true we can look at what
workers were paid before the minimum
wage it was well below where the minimum
wage was said for restaurant workers
that were studied in that most famous
study okay so this is not true the
minimum wage was binding there's a
second possibility it's absolutely
consistent with this with a perfectly
competitive market what's a possible
answer for why you can impose a minimum
wage in a perfectly competitive labor
market and have employment not go down
yeah the price that the firm charges
goes up but in a perfectly competitive
labor market that still wouldn't happen
okay you would still you might see some
price adjustment but you'd still see
some adjusting marginal product of labor
but what else about this diagram yeah
the firm's the firm's actually you're
close it would be the workers supply of
Labor's perfectly inelastic it's the
right idea if workers are perfectly
inelastic in their supply of labour then
the same amount of workers will work no
matter what the wage so basically you're
just going to essentially um you're just
could essentially end up you'd also you
you'd also in fact it's a good point
also got an inelastic demand the same
thing the supply or demand is inelastic
you'll end up here the supply or demand
is inelastic you'll end up with no
effect of a minimum wage so that's
another possibility but in fact we've
done a lot of studies so you could have
inelastic supply or demand but in fact
we've done lots of studies of supply and
demand these markets than that's not
true demand remember supply was largely
an elastic for men but it was somewhat
alas it elastic for women and these
low-income markets have a good mix of
men and women working in them demand has
been shown to be somewhat elastic so
it's not there neither supply demands
very elastic but they're sufficient
elastic that rules out a zero so the
third possibility and the one economists
have focused on is that we're not in a
competitive labor market they've focused
on a non competitive labor market just
like we just we discuss non-competitive
markets for goods with Monopoly and
oligopoly you can have non competitive
markets for labor ok it's a basic same
idea ok so now let's look at so when we
thought about let's go back thing about
perfect competition the basics of hurva
competition we thought I'd heard of
competition the basic idea was remember
I talked about laying out a bunch of
rugs and a bazaar in a market where you
could literally shop costlessly across
all the people selling their little fake
Eiffel Towers little statue Eiffel Tower
so you could perfectly shop it was easy
to go from carpet to carpet there was
full information the prices were posted
and so basically what you ended up was
perfectly ill perfectly elastic demand
facing any given firm any given firm if
they tried to charge one cent more for
their Eiffel Tower no
would buy it if they charged one set
less that immediately run out
okay everyone buy it well when we are
modeling labor market son discussed this
last time but not very well so I want to
come back to it when we're modeling
labor markets we're thinking about the
same feature of perfect competition but
here it's not consumers perfectly
competing over what it's not consumers
shopping over where to buy their goods
its workers shopping over where to work
its workers saying gee in a perfectly
competitive labor market the idea is I
know what I could earn at any firm and I
could easily shop across firms see where
I'm gonna work so if any firm tried to
pay me one cent less than the market
wage I'd never work there if I tried to
pay me one cent more than the market
wage every worker in the world would
want to work there so in a perfectly
competitive labor market any given firm
faces a perfectly elastic supply of
labor so we can see that in figure 16
for which we actually showed Multi skips
III covered 16 for which actually showed
in the last lecture remember the last
lecture I taught I was focused on this
downward sloping demand curve but I sort
of casually threw in this flat labor
supply curve and sort of botched
explaining it now I'm explaining it
hopefully more clearly which is to any
given firm the labor supply curve is
perfectly elastic
it's that firm because firm because
workers can perfectly shop across job
opportunities so if that firm tried to
pay less they get no workers so they
faced a perfectly elastic supply of
labor but in reality just like in
reality there's no such thing as a
perfectly competitive product market in
reality there's no signal perfectly
competitive labor market in fact we
can't shop easily across all possible
jobs and know what every job could pay
and the fact that we can't means that
firms on the labor market side will have
market power just like we talked about
monopolist and oligopolists having
market power over consumers through
barriers to entry firms
market power over workers because
workers can't perfectly shop across
their job alternatives okay so as a
result firms may be able to get away
with paying you less than what you might
earn elsewhere in a perfectly
competitive labor market firm could
never pay you less than what you're
worth elsewhere because you just go work
somewhere else but now if McDonald's
wants to pay you less than you're less
than you might get at Wendy's but it's
hard to go find out what Wendy's gonna
pay you you have to go a distance down
the road and you have to ask them and
you're sort of shy and it's embarrassing
then McDonald's might be able to get
away with paying you less than you might
earn at Wendy's
okay so this is very much peril to
monopolies in fact we call this a
monopsony a monopsony is a labor market
where firms have market power over
workers just like a monopoly is a Goods
market where firms have market power
over consumers okay now this is not so
crazy and in fact it applies very much
to me okay think about my situation at
MIT I've been here 25 years there's got
my 25th year rockin chair
although extra it's not a rocking chair
cuz it comes in the box with the rockers
off it and it arrived in my office so
it's sort of a short chair my wife's
five-foot and she always complains how
chairs are too big fur so she sad and
she's like there's a perfect chair for
me so now I have a non rocking rocking
chair in my office that she said safe
but anyway um I've been MIT for 25 years
it's gonna be really hard for me to move
I like my house I like my colleagues I
like my friends kind of I like my view
out the window it's gonna be kind of
hard for me to move moreover it would be
pretty hard for me to figure out what I
get paid if I moved I can't like go to
the University and say hey what would
you pay me if you hired me okay that'd
be kind of awkward okay I can't really
ask my colleagues what they make that's
kind of awkward so at the end of the day
mit has market power over me because I
don't really want to move and I can't
really figure out what I'd get paid if I
did move em MIT will exploit that market
power over me by paying me less that I
might earn elsewhere
okay and we knows the fact cuz
in academia the only way to get a race
is to go get an offer from someone else
okay
and have them say how much more they'll
pay you then you take that to your boss
and they say match this but if you're
not willing to do this as I'm phreak
frankly MIT knows not willing to do then
MIT can essentially under pay me okay so
basically and any responsible profit
maximizing or even non profit employer
will exploit this market power and
they'll pay me less than my market wage
okay and that means that MIT will learn
surplus on me okay in a perfectly
competitive labor market the firm or is
no surplus on the worker they pay the
worker their marginal revenue product so
if you go to this figure what am i
paying the worker what I'm paying them
is exactly their marginal revenue
product just like in a competitive
market for the goods a firm is selling
um at exactly their marginal cost so
just like a firm makes no surplus and a
perfectly competitive goods market a
firm hiring workers makes no surplus in
a perfect competitive labor market but
in a monopsony market the firm makes
surplus over me they pay me less than
they'd have to because they don't shop
and find a better opportunity okay now
do questions about how that market works
I'm not going to do all the math and
graphs it's all the same as monopoly
just flipping demand supply curves to
the pain in the ass I'm not going to do
it I just want you guys to understand
understand the intuition so please since
I went through this just in two other if
there questions about this or how it
works okay now let's take this part non
competitive labor market let's throw in
a minimum wage well as before if the
minimum wage is below what the firm was
already paying there's no effect so
let's assume it's a binding minimum wage
okay now let's say the binding minimum
wage is above what my true market wage
would be what my wage would be in the
perfectly competitive market so in a
perfectly competitive market my wage
would equal my marginal revenue product
of labor right that's comp that's at a
competitive market in this non
competitive market
my wages below my marginal revenue
product of labor firms are exploiting me
because I can't effectively shop for a
better job I don't want to where it's
hard to do so okay now in this non
competitive market if we set a minimum
wage that's higher than the marginal
revenue product of labor then it we
could the analysis is just like it's a
competitive firm once that Marchal when
wages higher the marginal revenue
product of labor it's just like a
competitive firm ok so it's not that
interesting the interesting case is what
if the minimum wage comes in and it's
above the wage I make but below the
marginal product revenue product of
labor so let's say McDonald's someone
working there yields a marginal revenue
product of labor of $10 but they're only
being paid $7 let's say you roll in
winnaman wage of $9 so above what
they're being paid now but below their
actual marginal revenue product of labor
will the firm fire that worker why not
yeah making surplus which is as long as
the marginal revenue product of labor is
bigger than the wage they love that
worker okay so before so let's just
write down the let's write down the
numbers of the example so imagine my
marginal revenue product of labor at
McDonald's is 10 but my wage is 7 okay
and then you cut me set a minimum wage
of 9 well 10 is still greater than 9 so
the Furnas no desire to fire me so all
you've done is just given me money and
where'd that money come from
this the surplus the firm earned so all
you've done is shifted the surplus from
you shifted producer surplus to consumer
it's from I'm sorry consumer surplus
consumers are the firm's to produce a
surplus the workers so when a monopsony
market a minimum wage is is doesn't
cause deadweight loss it's just sift
surplus around and that's a really
important outcome because that once
again says the government isn't always
bad
here okay this is just like if you want
to think about this graphically go back
to exactly the analysis we did of
regulating monopolies when we talk about
regulating monopolies we talked about if
a regulator comes in and sets a price
above them and up a set and sets a um
sets a price below the monopoly price
but above the competitive price it
reduced the deadweight loss of
monopolies it's the same thing and if
you set a minimum wage above the market
wage but below the marginal revenue
product of labor then you simply
transfer surplus to workers without
causing deadweight loss now that raised
the question of course is the minimum
wage in between the wage the marginal
product of labor well we don't know but
let's go back to the studies that
motivated this the very fact that the
minimum wage doesn't seem to cause
unemployment suggests we are hitting the
sweet spot suggests we are hitting the
sweet spot that we're basically managing
with the minimum wage policy at least to
date to essentially just find a way
without the government spending any
money to shift resources for businesses
to workers so what does this mean well
it means that around the level of
current minimum wages we can raise the
minimum wage by a small amount pretty
cautiously it doesn't necessarily mean
that a $15 minimum wage is okay so in
some sense the existence is the
important thing about empirical
economics you only learn the answer in
the range that you study it so for
example there been studies that have
looked at what happens if you have a ten
dollar minimum wage and those showed no
unemployment there haven't been studies
that show what happened to have a
fifteen dollar minimum wage now Seattle
just actually put in a fifteen dollar
minimum wage about two years ago so
actually can run the experiment the
early evidence is the Seattle 15 minute
$15 minimum wage did lower employment
that the Seattle $15 minimum wage
actually went above the marginal revenue
product of labor and once it's above
you're back in the competitive case
you're back in the case where you're
lowering employment yeah
competitive is the market well that's
that's the other question is how could
you increase so you tell me how could
you increase the competitors of a labor
market make it easier to tell like how
much money you'll get please
so Norway has a day every year they call
envy day which was yesterday I believe
would they literally can go online look
up anybody's income in Norway they
literally make public every single
person's tax return in Norway and you
can go online and look at what everybody
makes that would do it ok so you can
provide more information you could make
it easier to move between jobs for
example there's a lot of restrictions in
our labor market like non-compete
clauses which say that if you work for
one firm you can't ever go work for
another firm in that industry for X
years ok that makes it hard that gives
some monopsony power to firms etc so we
could do things which try to loosen the
flow of the labor market and that would
that would close this gap between wage
and marginal product of labor ok now
let's go back to Seattle just to include
this this doesn't mean the Seattle
policy was a bad one the bottom line is
what we learned from Seattle was that
basically employment fell a small amount
and a bunch of workers made a bunch more
money so is that good or bad well it
depends if you want to be to lost their
job it's really bad if you're one of the
workers we've got to raise up to $15 an
hour it's good how do you weigh them
against each other that's exactly what
talked about in a couple lectures so
this kind of once we start talking about
normative economics about as a policy
good or bad there's typically trade-offs
and this is a classic example what we're
learning here is is the minimum wage in
the range we are now right now the
federal minimum wage at 725 okay could
the evidence suggests it could easily
rise without causing that trade-off the
emissary's we could increase the federal
minimum wage by some non-trivial amount
9 up to at least up to nine or ten
dollars without causing much of a
trade-off but once you get too far ahead
of that there starts to be a trade-off
question about that yeah
oh yeah many states don't have their own
minimum wage Massachusetts is at 11 but
we're pretty unusual where we're one of
the higher ones a number of states at
725 is the minimum wage okay so and the
evidence seems to be from states like
Massachusetts and others which are in
the sort of 1011 dollar range it doesn't
seem to lower employment so he was like
we could clearly we'd be safe raising a
federal minimum wage we would simply be
transferring resources and not causing
unemployment yeah that's a great
question so what I assumed was I assumed
firms would just say ah you got me I'm
gonna first on my profits at workers
burns don't have to do that firms could
say well if gimmicky workers mom gonna
raise my price now if it's a competitive
output market that shouldn't happen
right because in a competitive output
market um well no marginal cost goes up
it's not clear it's not clear whether
that would happen or not and the
evidence is that is unclear whether
heightened wage causes higher prices or
whether it just comes out of profits we
don't know yet okay all right so that's
what I say about labor markets now I
want to move on and talk about capital
markets now as confusing as our
discussion of labor markets was that's
easy compared to capital markets capital
are it's a lot harder to understand and
that's because capital itself labor some
to get your hands around it's the time
you spend at work capital is this sort
of amorphous thing that I've kept sort
of pushing off defining so I'll define
it now we talk about capital is this
vague collection of buildings and
machines the other stuff that goes into
production okay and we know where labor
comes from it comes from our work
but where does capital come from well
capital is a harder concept but there's
one unifying thread that all elements of
capital have which is they represent the
diversion of current consumption towards
future consumption capital is
about diverting consuming today towards
consuming in the future okay in fact the
original cost of capital came from
farmers farmers every year when they
would pick their pick their grain they
had a choice they could eat all the
grain or they could save some to plant
for next year's grain now the more they
saved the more that have next year but
the less they'd have today so farmers
faced the trade-off could substitute
today literally consumption today or
consumption next year
that's cap but that's we mean by capital
in other words in today's market economy
the link is not that direct but it's the
same basic idea that firms have a choice
firms and their investors have a choice
they can take what they make and eat it
now or they can invest it in having more
in the future
okay so basically when we think about
capital we're not going to think about
capital's physical capital really think
about capitalists financial capital what
links all types of capital is there
financial aspect what O'Lakes bussiness
and buildings is all the aspect that by
putting money to them today you have
less you can spend on fun stuff today
but more you'll be able to spend
tomorrow and it's this financial aspect
that links all forms of capital now how
do firms get the money to invest in
machines and buildings and stuff like
that they get it through going to the
capital market where two firms get this
money that they invest they get it
through going to the capital market okay
which is basically the pool of money
that firms can draw on to make their
investments so think of it literally as
I'm a firm I want to build a building a
bio machine I literally go over and
there's a big pool of money and I have
to take the money out of there to go buy
my machine or build my building okay and
where does the money in that pool come
from it comes from household savings
decisions so the capital market is a
market with the demand for capital comes
from workers from
firm's interest in investing and having
more in the future the supply of capital
comes from people's decisions to safe
and essentially the money firms use to
buy stuff is borrowed from people and
that's the bottom line of how capital
markets work so just as the firm the
amount the supply of labor that
determines how many workers our firm can
hire comes from your decision of how
hard to work the supply of capital that
determines how many machines a firm can
buy comes from your decision of how hard
to save okay so let's look at figure 16
five equilibrium in Capital Markets okay
we have let's start with the demand we
already talked last lecture demand for
capital the demand for capital comes
from the marginal revenue product of
capital it's a marginal product of the
next machine so the demand comes from
the marginal product of the next machine
times the price the firm can get for its
output which is the marginal revenue
product of capital so it's the same
logic as for labor there's nothing
interesting there same logic as for
labor okay the supplies what's more
interesting here where does supply come
from the supply comes from household
savings how much money is around for
firms to actually get to get these
machines and how do they get it they
borrow and what do they borrow at they
borrow at the interest rate I so I
represents the rate that firms pay
households to get their money so a
firm's it's think of this as we'll talk
about how it really works but in theory
the idea is little think of literally a
market place in the center of town
downtown Boston Haymarket there's like
this market place and a firm comes and
says I need to borrow money to buy a
machine and a person's there with their
savings and they say well I'll loan you
some money what is your straight you're
gonna give me and that's the market for
capital so where the supply of capital
meets the demand of capital yields the
interest rate so basically what this
means is as the interest rates higher
what that means is I have to pay people
back more to borrow their money so an
interest rate of 10% if I borrow $10
from you I pay you back a dollar 10 next
period ok 5 or $10 maybe back a dollar
10 next period
if this rates 20 percent if I borrow $10
if I bought a dollar I'm sorry if I
borrow a dollar from you I pay a dollar
10 next period 5 20 percent and I borrow
a dollar I pay back a dollar 20 next
period etc ok
so basically that is essentially how the
transaction works and the key point here
is the reason the supply curve is upward
sloping is the more you're willing to
pay me for my money the more I'm willing
to lend you so if you come to me and say
give me a dollar and next I'll give you
back a dollar I'm like I don't know why
would I do that say give me down like
she'll give you back a dollar 10 you're
like okay now I'm interested dollar 20
I'm very interested dollar 50 for sure
little ladies give me my money make sure
I get back 50% more why not okay so
basically the higher the interest rate
the more I'm willing to loan the firm
and therefore you get an upward sloping
supply curve okay now of course in
reality people don't actually don't sit
in Haymarket downtown Boston get money
to firms in reality this transaction
happens through capital markets and
essentially there are three mechanisms
by which implicitly I loan money to
firms okay the first is I could
literally hat by corporate debt
I could literally loan the money to
firms I could literally go and the firm
could say I General Motors and issuing a
bond this is third bond issuing a bond
and the way that bond works is I promise
that for every dollar you spend buying
my bond
you'll get one plus I dollars back at
the end
okay or next year say cuz I'll own the
bond is so literally you're loaning the
money to the firm by buying you're
buying their promise to pay you back now
a second way you can loan money to the
firm is through investing in their
equity you can buy their stock the way
this works is GM says to you by
a piece of me and you'll get paid back
not some fix interest rate but you got
to pay back according to how well GM
does so with a with corporate debt
I get paid back something that's
predetermined when I buy stock or equity
I don't get back a predetermined amount
I get back some depends on how well the
company does but it's the same basic
idea I'm giving the company some money
today
in return for am I getting more money I
hope tomorrow
that's the diversion of consumption from
today to tomorrow and the third thing I
could do is I can put it in the bank now
how is that loaning to companies because
the bank then loans it to companies why
do banks say they'll pay you interest on
your money okay why do banks say why did
banks go in crazy I'll give you one it's
used it used to be interesting now it's
a 1% 2% when I was a kid it was like 10%
12% will give you lots of money and and
we'll talk later about why it was so
higher so much higher when I was a kid
okay
why are banks so eager to do that it's
not at the goodness of their heart it's
because when you give them dollars they
turn around loan them they add a bunch
feed straight and loan them out to firms
those dollars you're loaning you're
giving a banks and they're paying you
two percent interest their loan to firms
at six percent okay and that's why
bankers are rich okay so basically the
reason a bank exists is because it's a
way corporate debt and equity markets
are hard and complicated it's much
easier to put your money in a bank you
put your money in your bank but when you
put your money in a bank you're
essentially loaning it to companies
that's essentially what you're doing so
through these mechanisms we have a
capital market we're essentially by my
putting money away and diverting from
today's consumption I'm longing to firm
they'll produce more and they'll pay me
back more in the future okay questions
about that okay so let's talk about the
supply curves from we comes from we know
what the demand curves comes from it's
just simply comes to the marginal
revenue product of capital where is
supply curve come from the supply curve
comes from what we call intertemporal
choice economists like as I said he kind
of like clean fancy names on things that
makes us helps us get paid more money
okay it just means
choosing overtime okay intertemporal
choice incredible choice is essentially
about how do you decide how much to save
what's going to determine that it's
gonna be your decision of how much you
value money today versus valuing money
tomorrow okay so for ease let's imagine
I'm considering two periods this year
versus next year ah when I talk about
Pierre is only about days and years and
whatever we don't it's the basic logic
is about now versus the future whether I
say days or years doesn't really matter
you know right now the point is I'm just
talking about today versus the future so
let's say about this year versus next
year and let's imagine prices aren't
gonna change I'll come back to prices
next lecture but let's imagine the price
of goods aren't going to go up there's
no inflation in this economy okay which
is roughly true today okay
and let's suppose I'm gonna take next
year off to care for my children lord
knows why I'd want to do that when their
youngest ones 19 but imagine I they
still need my care okay so let's say I
take next ed this this example gets
dated okay I take next year off to care
for my children okay so let's say and
let's say my income is $80,000 a year
okay now here is my but I'm gonna take
next year off unpaid okay so I'm gonna
work this year for 80k next year I'm
gonna take off unpaid so I have a couple
of choices I could work this year earn
my ebk spend my ATK and have nothing
next year to live on
I could work this year and eat nothing
and save it all out of 80 K to live on
or some combination in between and we
could ilist what the key difference is
every dollar that I don't consume this
year that I saved to consume next year
earns interest and that's where the
trade-off comes so let's look at figure
sixteen six I face this is a familiar
looking optimization diagram now my
optimization is not over Pizza versus
cookies but my optimization is over
consumption in this period versus
consumption experience a bit
mind-blowing okay we're a little science
fiction here right okay when I don't
talk about choosing between two goods
like leisure and consumption or cookies
in
Pizza now I'm about to time periods
consumption today versus consumption
tomorrow but that's the key thing about
the tools we learned with consumer
choice those tools are incredibly
powerful just and just shove your
problem into that framework and he's
they're going to shove our problem into
this framework the problem we're facing
is how to decide how much is safe
well savings is a bad just like Labor's
are bad what do we do when we have a bad
to model we don't model the bad we model
the complementary good so our choice is
how much do I consume today
how much do I is how much somebody could
soon today and how much am I gonna save
okay well saving is a bad but the
complement is but the other way to think
about it is how much consume today
versus how much about to consume
tomorrow then that's two goods and I can
model them against each other and that's
what I do in Figure 16-6 I model
consumption today versus consumption
next year so here's my choices as I said
if I consume everything today I'm at the
x-intercept at 8,000 I have 80,000 to
consume today nothing next year if I
consume everything next year what do I
get
well let's say the interest rate is 10
percent what that means is then I'll
have eighty eight thousand next year why
we'll have more next year because by
saving iearned interest by diverting my
consumption to the future I earn
interest at ten percent that means I
would have eighty eight thousand next
year so my budget constraint is aligned
with the slope minus one plus I my
budget rate is a line with the slope
minus one plus I in other words the
price of consumption today in terms of
consumption tomorrow is minus one plus I
okay let me think about let me see it
against really confusing okay the price
of consuming today instead of consuming
tomorrow
assuming no inflation so prices are the
same in the market it's minus one plus I
think about that I find it useful to
think about to the labor case for
parallel in the labor case
what did we say was the price of leisure
what was the price of leisure stone
raise their hand and tell me in the
labor yeah
the wage why right so by the same logic
gene tell me why is the price of
consuming today one plus I the
opportunity cost remember we are an
annoying discipline with a dismal
science we're telling you hey enjoy that
cookie but by the way if your weren't
eating that cookie you could have one
plus I cookies tomorrow okay so just
like we nag you for sitting around
watching TV
we nag you for eating today by saying
hey the more you consume today the less
you can have tomorrow and in fact that
trade-off is that for every cookie you
could submit you forego one plus I
cookies tomorrow okay so that's the
budgeted straight the slope is the
opportunity cost of consuming today in
terms of tomorrow's consumption or next
year's consumption okay which is one
plus I that's the slope of the budget
range the opportunity cost and then then
we say okay well that's the opportunity
cost that's the budget tree well how do
I decide well then we know how to make
decisions which is go to utility
function you can write down a utility
function which is a function of C 1 and
C 2 now what is C C is all my pizza
cookies but we're starting a grading it
up just like our utility function last
time was a function of leisure and
consumption okay which is a consumption
was the sort of bundle of goods you eat
unless you're is this thing now we're
saying okay our utility function as a
function of this trade-off now you might
say wait a second how can both those be
utility function the answer is you have
some meta utility function that includes
consumption today tomorrow leisure pizza
cookies etc but we could sort of think
about this in sequential steps first we
decide how we're gonna split our income
then we can decide how much know what to
spend it on each period then you do a
separate consumer maximization decision
but our first questionably how am I
gonna split my income well that's to be
a function of my taste for consumption
in this period versus next period
and the price the bank will pay me for
delaying consumption till next period
now what happens question about that now
what happened this scenario when the
interest rate goes up what do you what
do you think happens the each rate goes
up yeah right so what do you think you
should do you think you'll what do you
think'll happen your consumption
consumption pattern
yeah spend less today and save more
because rewarded and why is that not
necessarily true yeah because of what
two effects income and substitution
effects
you gave exactly intuition that the
substitution effect gives you the
substitution effect is exactly right if
the price of contain interest rate goes
up that's like the price of consumption
today going up and if the price of
something goes up the substance Veck
says you do less of it but if they just
rate goes up you're richer and if you're
rich you do more of everything including
consuming today singham effect goes the
other way it's like labor once again
that's why income substitute effects why
we bothered telling you so okay because
income solution effects in these cases
go against each other let's look at
figure sixteen seven okay in Figure
sixteen seven we started point a okay
now imagine the interest rate doubles to
twenty percent okay
now match the interest rate doubles as
you said that pivots the budget
constraint upwards you could still
consume only eighty thousand this year
but now for every dollar you save you
get a dollar twenty next year okay that
has two effects on your decision the
substitution effect we get by drawing an
imaginary budget constraint that's the
dashed line tangent to the original
indifference curve but at the new slope
by definition that means you consume
less today okay you consume less today
by definition if the price of something
goes up the substance vector always says
you do less of it you could
last today which means you'll save more
remember
savings savings is just income minus
consumption in period one okay
so just as labor was 24 minus leisure
and so if we just solved for a leisure
we could get labor savings is just
income minus consumption period 1 so if
we solve for consumption period 1 we get
savings ok people see that now so
basically the point here is the
substitution effect says well gee the
price of consumption period 1 just went
up it's more costly in terms of future
consumption I'm gonna do less of it
they're my savings is gonna go up
so substitution effect says you save
more but the income effect says wait a
second you're now richer every dollar of
your savings you were doing now yields
twice as much an interest if you're
richer you'll consume more of everything
including period 1 consumption seeing of
effect takes you back the other way
now what think of effect dominates or
not we don't know in this case it
doesn't dominate in this case you still
on net end up consuming less than period
1 and saving more but we don't know
what's gonna dominate ok and in fact the
evidence here is incredibly weak I want
spend a long time in the evidence
because it's not noon as interesting and
strong as labor supply the evidence is
incredibly weak even about the sign and
let's come to the intuition it was given
for why well think about your your think
about how people make savings decisions
lots of people are savings goals I want
to have X by the time I retire typical
way if you ask Hill about their savings
if you ask them they typically say I
want to make sure I have X in the bank
in case I'm an accident I want to make
sure I've Y by the time I retire well on
those models if the interest rate goes
up savings rates go down because after
all to hit a target with a higher
interest rate I can save less so it's
actually not that surprising that you'd
have a higher rate leading to less
savings it's kind of intuitive actually
if people have savings targets a hires
ready to lead to less ami so they can
get to their target more easily so
actually we don't even know which way
this goes it's one I think one of the
great unsolved mysteries in economics
empirically is we we once again
we typically assume and with a gun to my
head I would sort of say it's probably
true that higher straight leads to more
savings but the evidence on which that
rest is pretty weak okay and the key
point for you is to understand it's
uncertain and it depends on whether
income and substitution effects dominate
questions about that okay so now let's
step back and put it all together and
think about you making your like
decision about life you could think
about your decisions about your life in
sort of three steps okay step one is you
decide how hard to work okay step once
you decide how much money's you want
want to make well that's about
maximizing utility over consumption
leisure step two is having decided how
much you're gonna make and that yields
your labor
step two is citing how much you're gonna
make you said well how do I want to
spread that over time how much already
consumed today versus tomorrow well
that's about a temporal choice
that's about deciding on C 1 versus C 2
and that's gonna yield your savings
step three is now that I know how much
I'm going to consume each period now
Anna maximize utility across all my
goods I might want to consume x2 across
all the goods I want to consume that was
our original cookies and pizza example
so might you could think I'm sort of a
hierarchy little set of you consumer
optimization problems that you're gonna
solve now you might say well gee John
that's sort of confusing because in fact
the interest rate and how much again my
savings could determine how hard I work
right let's say the interest rate goes
way up and I have a savings target I
have to work less hard to hit that
savings target and I'd say to you good
for you take more advanced economics
more vast economics we recognizes one
integrated whole and we allow these
system to affect each other
okay but for here just think of as six
separate separate Abul steps
okay independent steps but in practice I
hope you can see the steps we'll be
integrating it affect each other okay
think of it if the price of a good you
really want to buy goes up a lot not
only you buy less of that good you might
save more to buy it and work harder so
you can imagine how these things
but for now we'll keep them separable
okay question about that okay next time
we're to come back and talk about all
these six stuff in capital markets and
how we make decisions about how much to
save and things like that